foreign
go to Marie in Fargo what's up Marie how
we doing
good hey uh talking directly into your
phone
yes can you hear me
it's a little bit wobbly there
keep going we'll see if we'll give it a
shot yes what's your question okay so I
mean the fourth generation in our family
business my boyfriend and I have been
together for four and a half years my
dad wants me to get a prenup neither my
boyfriend or I want to but my brother
did recently get divorced and he did
have one
okay so I uh usually my thoughts on
prenups I'm not a fan of them
um it's it's kind of like it's planning
the end of something you're going into
it
when you've got something like a family
business here's what your a prenup can
protect you from less from your husband
your future husband and more from your
future husbands
cousins sisters brothers or roommate
or your husband heaven forbid
um gets sick and passes away or gets in
a wreck and some sister or some cousin
sues you guys for your does that make
sense it just separates it all
um okay that's where a prenup can be
very useful it's less about I don't
trust him or I wouldn't be marrying him
it's more about if he something happens
to him which is why we have insurance
that's why we have Wills because
something will happen to all of us
um the heaven forbid something does
happen to him it protects your business
it takes protects your stake in the
business it protects the whole thing
from anybody coming out of the woodwork
to try to take a piece of it
okay so what's your net worth I didn't
even know that was possible yes it is
me personally
not
not that young but
um the business does around
6 million a year
that's a lot of dollars and so you would
be inheriting the business or some
portion I wouldn't inherit it I need to
buy myself in but yes
and so what I would do is take a job I
would start working there if that's what
you wanted to do and take it oh no I
haven't for the last decade okay do you
have enough money to buy in
uh currently I have a sliver of the pie
what's your buy-in going to be
uh I have I only have three percent of
the business
apparently you only have three percent
of the money it's going to take to buy
the business or you're slowly buying it
piece by piece over time of the business
currently uh okay okay and your
boyfriend what is his financial
situation
more than I do
okay
I mean we we don't advise against
prenups in situations where there is an
inordinate amount of wealth uh that
you're coming into with this very
lucrative jewelry business so it is
something that you may want to look into
and it sounds like you guys are doing it
approaching with the right Spirit of
you're going hey I'm not doing this
because I'm nervous about marrying this
guy I'm doing it to protect us from
crazy down the line and that's that's
the way you want to think about it
and
neither of us want to get one but my
parents do and I'm just here here's
here's what I recommend said like I'm
not getting one
and that's how I feel as well but I I
just I don't know what to do
um I would sit down this is going to be
worth
um
500 or a thousand bucks to do this
um because of what what's at stake here
um I would sit down with an attorney and
your local community and tell them what
your dad has told you tell them what you
all want to do tell them what tell them
what I told you that this is less about
him and more worried about something
down the road your attorney an attorney
May advise you well he won't be an owner
you will and he would have part of your
estate like so there may be all kinds of
different ways involved here okay that
may be able to avoid a prenup I think
you have to get past the idea that a
prenup is y'all planning for your
divorce or you're planning for your
husband to screw you over that's not
what that's not we're talking about here
okay
um
one red flag for me is your husband
already planting his feet in the ground
against your dad
I'm not doing that I'm that attitude
it's before you even walk down the aisle
makes me that's a red flag for me as
someone who's just talked to a million
different uh a million different couples
sure that tells me he's more invested in
his ego and his pride than in
what's the best way I can honor my wife
what's the best way I can keep her and
this business safe and the best way we
can be connected and unified as a family
and I have to look in the mirror and say
no I got some crazy cousins or I've got
some crazy what like you know what I
mean like he's got to be able to do that
and say okay this actually protects you
in the case I get hit by a bus
okay see what I'm saying I never thought
of it from that point of view
so it's but it's it's it's a much
I get what your dad's trying to protect
his business and he's trying to love his
daughter the best he can I don't fault
him for a second I also don't fault him
for being overly cautious and you having
to say hey that's too cautious I don't
call I don't I don't um uh I don't have
any heartburn about you and your husband
saying do we really are not interested
in signing a prenup we're going into
this thing together
um I get that too that's why I would get
a third party who has no stake in any of
the family stuff or the drama and it's
just going to give you wisdom particular
to the business to your situation your
state and local laws all that kind of
stuff so that's where I would go but
think bigger um and again I'm not for
prenups I don't like him at all I I
don't like him at all but there is a
time and a place for him it's a good
word and uh with this situation he is
your boyfriend and so unless we are
really like we're about to get married
this is not a thing we have to deal with
right now I mean we don't even know if
he's gonna propose what this looks like
down the line but it's good to at least
get some information from the lawyer
going hey what does this look like on
paper in a worst case scenario what
would actually happen and that will give
you some peace and confidence moving
forward with it or not moving forward
with it that's right